today's draft stars that the patriots
let leave town stars that the patriots
let leave town obviously this is in
reference to hashtag tommy possibly
leaving town here is the question
christopher the patriots
currently have two players under
contract with cap hits above 10 million
dollars
for this year one is stefan gilmore at
18.6 million who is the other patriot
who is under contract with a cap hit
above 10 million dollars oh my gosh who
is the uh cap hit above 10 million
dollars on the patriots who am i missing
here okay i'm gonna say dante hightower
boom
man i'm good whoa
what up what up dante hightower
i mean you get the first pick it was
it's you it's not a long list with the
patriots of guys like that right you
gotta just did i just got lucky and
finally got to his name there but um all
right so whatever the hell the title of
this draft is star players the patriots
let leave town okay i think one the one
they let leave town here not too long
ago chandler jones is gonna be my first
pick because
as cutthroat as the new england patriots
have been over the years and been
willing to make
really tough decisions and not be
emotional emotionally attached to some
of their star players who have helped
them out chandler jones is really one of
the few that was in the prime of his
career and just butting into a superstar
i mean he obviously was the best pass
rusher on the patriots when he was there
now had a little like issue in the
offseason that one year i don't know he
went to the police department right
because either they thought he might
have took a synthetic marijuana that was
the story out there whatever it may be
and that seemed to be where the
relationship went wrong but man chandler
jones no question about it has been one
of the best best pass rushers in
football the last three or four years i
mean he's been phenomenal he's had years
of 17 sacks and of course this year he
had 19 sacks so i think that to me is
the one that jumps out more than the
rest
you know they get to the point where
they decide that they know a guy is
going to be
in heavy demand and free agency so they
trade him ahead of time instead of
letting him leave and taking the
compensatory draft pick they trade him
away and get more now that we see them
do that all the time with guys and uh
they did that with chandler jones and
that's the biggest example of a guy that
maybe they'd like to have but they would
have been in a position where they had
to pay him a lot more than maybe they
value those positions all right
well this one for me is a guy who who
ultimately has been the subject of three
first-round picks in the national
football league he was a first-round
pick of the saints in 2013. he was
traded to the patriots for a first round
pick and the patriots then traded him
for a first round pick to the la rams
and that's receiver brandon cooks and
you know he never really became the guy
they thought he was going to be in new
england is he going to be the next slot
receiver stand out there is he going to
be on the outside is going to be you
know it wasn't it just it didn't work
right and they were able to flip him for
a first round pick and so it was a
win-win you know he got a great contract
with the rams right out of the gates
sight unseen and now he's the subject of
trade talks again uh not significant not
not high-end not anything that feels
imminent but there is a thought that as
the rams try to manage the salary cap
this may be a guy they have to flip i'd
be shocked if he gets another first
round picking compensation but hey if
muhammad sunu is worth a two maybe
brandon cooks is worth a one but i got
brandon cooks as my my first round pick
for guys as as a first round pick and
who was traded for two other first round
picks my first round pick as a former
star who the other patriots let leave
yep uh yeah i mean you know what i i
forgot about him really but you're right
i mean it's kind of interesting that
whole story of how they acquired them
you're right getting rid of them doing
that you know had a good little
uh
short stint there in new england but you
know yeah brandon cook's interesting
here going forward too with him those
rumors being out there got the
concussion issues we'll see where that
all goes all right my next one i'm going
with wes welker you know you won a
receiver i'm going wes welker i mean you
know that was a huge move at the time
right i mean wes welker i think we all
saw had you know such an important role
on that
new age new england offense that went
from you know hey the corey dillon and
we're gonna run the ball and then brady
will just make some clutch throws at the
end of the game to all of a sudden hey
these rules on defenses have changed
about touching the receivers and it
became wow new england throws the ball
every play and they abuse you over the
middle with wes welker and i think is a
him letting him leave town and you know
when he left new england you could say
he was the best receiver in the history
of the new england patriots and
certainly had a special combination with
tom brady but he leaves town and goes to
another great offense with peyton
manning and the denver broncos and of
course strings together a few good years
there as well but nothing like he did in
new england uh but that was uh pretty
big news when wes welker was replaced by
julian edelman and they let him leave
town
well and and the the other reason why
that was a big deal chris because he
wasn't traded he's a guy who became a
free agent yeah and remember all that
angst all that acrimony with the
negotiations with the patriots and they
thought they were going to be able to
keep him and he left for the broncos and
there were some hard feelings there and
and you're right he never was the same
guy he dropped from 354
receiving yards in new england in 2012.
down to 778 the the first year he was
with the broncos and that was the best
year he ever had there he's only there
two seasons we feel like he was with the
broncos a long time he was there two
years
and had
had fewer yards in two years than he had
his last year with the patriots but that
was a big deal because he's that one guy
that they didn't control him they wanted
him and he said see you later yeah no
you're right that was uh that was a big
deal i was there you know in new england
a little bit when he was asking for some
of the new money and the and wanted a
new contract and i think felt a little
disrespected that way uh and of course
as i've always said the the the
prevailing notion with wes welker in the
new england building was that he played
better when he was pissed off uh so they
made sure he was pissed off a lot
well uh one guy who was definitely
pissed off when he was abruptly traded
from the patriots to the raiders was
richard seymour oh
and and i remember there was a period of
time where
richard seymour maybe wasn't even going
to show up yeah and and i remember doing
the research on what are the rules if he
never shows up is the trade voided what
rights did the raiders have
and uh you know he went on to play four
seasons with the raiders made the pro
bowl twice he went from 2006 to 2010
without a pro bowl appearance in his
second year with the raiders he was a
pro bowler same thing as the third year
so he did well with the raiders
obviously they didn't make it to the
playoffs so he didn't have that same
ultimate success that he enjoyed in new
england but seymour that was really the
stunner that was the first big name from
that team that won three super bowls in
four years it got thrown overboard by
bill belichick underscoring the reality
that he's willing to rip the name off
the back of the jersey and make the best
decision for the football team no matter
how how important that guy had been in
the past yeah no i mean that was a
shocker and richard seymour was such a
staple of the success of the patriots in
their first three super bowl wins mayor
richard servant to me i mean richard
seymour excuse me is like he's one of
those guys i look at right now to go
he's a hall of fame football player he
deserves to be in the hall of fame the
stats are never going to tell the story
about richard seymour it's not about
that it's the fact that he was a
mountain of a man he was immovable and
he could dominate in the run game he
could push the pocket in the pass game
he was one of the best defensive players
i ever played against uh so yes i i
think uh you know that was a good pick
by you it really was he was on my list
he was probably gonna go next to me next
for me all right the next one i'm going
back to receiver i'm gonna go with dion
branch here i mean hey the fact that the
the patriots uh i wanna make sure they
traded him to the seahawks right am i
right about yeah yeah okay good that was
they were very contentious contractual
dispute back in yeah and they were like
screw it we're not giving him we're not
giving him we're not giving him they
finally traded him traded him to the
seattle seahawks i mean two years after
he had won the or maybe just a year no
it was two years after he had won the
mvp of the super bowl in that eagles
patriots super bowl showdown you know he
goes to the seattle seahawks and of
course goes to a super bowl there as the
number one target for matt hasselbeck
and mike holmgren in that offense but
you know that's just another another
example of the patriarch just not
blinking and never letting one player
hold their team and organization hostage
and it's the reason and a big reason and
i just don't think a lot of
organizations and coaches have the guts
to do it but it's the reason they've
dominated for 20 years because they can
just chop off that emotional attachment
part of their body or lives or whatever
it is and they can do what's ever best
for the football team and that's allowed
them to stay at the top of the mountain
for a long time
and that's particularly appropriate as
they close in on whatever decision
they're going to make about yeah brady
we talk so much about what does tom want
but what does bill belichick want that
is a big part of this as well all right
i am really going to make you mad with
my last pick
right
um because look we haven't applied any
time constraints oh here we go
what i don't know i don't know where
you're going with this
well a guy that you
included in the draft not that long ago
when we did a draft of guys who should
have made a draft day power play jim
plunkett
over patriot won two super bowls with
the raiders great
far better elsewhere than he was with
the patriots and just a reminder for
anyone out there that just assumes the
patriots have been this powerhouse
forever i remember back in the 70s they
were not a good organization they were
not really a good organization until the
crafts bought the team in 1994. they
were always now they've been to
uh one super bowl when they upset the 85
dolphins and prevented us from having a
rematch of the bears and the dolphins in
super bowl xx but they really hadn't
done much and they'd always been just
kind of there and jim plunk at the first
overall pick in 1971 and he did his time
and he moved on to the 49ers for a
couple years and then it all fell
together for him with the raiders and he
won a couple of super bowls so jim
plunkett that's almost it's against the
spirit of the draft it's against the
spirit of the driver you know we're
talking about this draft as it pertains
to bill belichick and what's going on
with tom brady and belichick's
belichick's willingness to let his
players walk out the door get rid of
them maybe before they're done you're a
jerk you're always here you're such a
lawyer fine prince snarky comment
there's no fine print yeah there's no
there's no fine print it was a very
broad category and in fact i
specifically when introducing the draft
said stars who left new england not star
players because i had pete carroll in my
backpack
yeah of course you did yes of course you
did very well he was the he was the last
coach of the patriots before bill
belichick well and he won a super bowl
elsewhere okay well just for for funsies
here i mean what are some other ones we
had lawyer malloy we missed out on that
right that was tyler ty law damn i
forgot about that one jamie collins
vince wilfork
randy moss right you you got a ben
watson is another guy i had written down
anybody kobe brisette jacoby burcette
logan ryan logan ryan jimmy garoppolo
i mean yeah yeah malcolm butler i mean
it is amazing it's amazing it really
paul sheared has done well with the
cults and with the patriots there's a
lot of guy and that's the thing
the players are commodities you know on
most teams it's the kicker and the
punter that is viewed as completely and
totally fungible and we can get rid of
them and find somebody else bill
belichick's attitude toward everyone on
the team
well you're just a piece in the machine
and we will pull you out and put another
one in and that's that there is no
emotional attachment of any kind and i
think that's why
he's the way he is with tom brady
there's always been a wall with tom
brady because when the time comes to
make that difficult decision a decision
that we assumed bill belichick would
have had to have made a long time ago
but when that time comes he wants to be
able to make a dispassionate decision
that is driven by one thing and one
thing only the best interest of the team
in other words how are we going to win
more games with him or without him and
we'll find out an answer to that within
the next weekend you know as a pr and
we'll talk more about this in pftot as
to the timing but uh i think we'll know
by by next week at this time for sure
whether or not he's staying
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports